[Música]
eu já tive várias cores de cabelo juro
mesmo comecei com vermelho fui pro azul
futuro ro chu e e eu percebi que cada
uma dessas cores ela estava marcando uma
fase da minha vida eu lembro de cada uma
dessas jóias com carinho muito grande e
antes dessa júlia que vocês estão vendo
aqui agora de cabelo verde era mais
velho de cabelo cor de rosa foi uma
júlia que permitiu ter um olhar
diferente para matemática que se
entregou para a divulgação científica e
caiu de cabeça na educação
e há mais ou menos uma semana atrás eu
senti que eu estava na hora de mudar
e foi assim que eu cheguei no verde a
reação das pessoas são as mais diversas
e uma pergunta a que mais apareceu foi
porque o verde
eu respondi a ela várias vezes e eu
reparei que essa pergunta na verdade ela
tinha uma grande similaridade com uma
das perguntas que eu mais responde na
minha vida toda por conta da carreira
que escolhi seguir que é porque a
matemática é bom quando decidir fazer
licenciatura em matemática as pessoas já
me questionavam do porquê matemática e
quando eu entrei na graduação essa
pergunta não me abandonou
ela só aparecia durante as aulas durante
os estágios e eu pergunto aqui pra vocês
em algum momento da vida de vocês já
passou na cabeça de vocês do porquê
matemática
eu já pensei várias vezes sobre essa
pergunta e eu tive um grande prazer de
ver muitas pessoas também respondendo
ela uma das respostas possíveis para
essa pergunta é que a matemática está aí
para ajudar a gente a viver nesse mundão
de que ela tá aí a gente ajudar a gente
a conferir um troco haver revestimento
nós piso quanto que a gente precisa
comprar o quanto que vai rever algum
tipo de investimento
isso é matemática certamente de fato
isso é matemática mas
se fosse só isso aí eu quem vou
perguntar porque matemática então porque
na escola a gente vê tantas teoremas
tagarelas detalhes porque essa discussão
esse tipo de resposta ele abre espaço
para uma argumentação de que a
matemática é inútil e pra quem disse
isso eu confesso que eu vou ter que
concordamos com essas pessoas mas talvez
por um motivo diferente
inútil é o que não é útil e útil do
latim é algo que a qualidade do que se
pode ser usado então é aquilo que o
valor está em sua aplicação então se
algo que é útil o valor que está em sua
aplicação a gente pode dar um exemplo de
que algo útil é por exemplo um celular
a gente usa o celular para se conectar a
falar com as pessoas buscar informações
então o celular por si só é útil mas a
matemática a matemática é inútil o valor
dela está nela mesma e tá isso basta
você perguntar para um pesquisador de
matemática pura porque que ele está
respondendo às perguntas que ele está
respondendo ele vai te dizer porque elas
são ótimas perguntas
ele não está preocupado se alguém vai
usar aquilo que ele está respondendo
para usar em alguma coisa que a gente
pode exibir ficar isso por exemplo com
números primos os números primos
eles são algo que a gente discute desde
antes de cristo existe um brother
chamado euclides ele escreveu um livro é
um livro que ele é o segundo livro mais
publicado e mais transcrito depois da
bíblia e dentro desse livro que chama os
elementos ele tem uma visão de número
como um comprimento e o que significa o
cliente vai dizer que se você pegar uma
barrinha de um tamanho qualquer e você
chama ela de um você vai poder juntar
duas dessas baias do mesmo tamanho falar
que são dois e junta três falar que é o
3 e assim por diante
e pra ele ele dizia que os números
primos
são números em que quando você for 30
preenchê-los vai conseguir preencher
completamente usando apenas segmentos do
seu próprio tamanho ou segmento de
tamanho e quando digo preencher os
outros dizendo saber preencher com os
segmentos do mesmo tamanho real mais
segura aqui na minha mão
vamos começar tudo está bom a gente
sempre começa falando dos primos a
partir do 2o 2 ele consegue ser
preenchido com uma bomba duas barrinhas
de tamanho ou com uma única barrinha de
tamanho 2
se a gente pegar o 3 é o mesmo caso que
a gente consegue preencher ele com três
bairros de tamanho e também com uma
barriguinha de tamanho 3 mas a gente
tenta com preencher companheiro de
tamanho 2 ou vai faltar vai sobrar então
o 3 é prima mas o 4 além de bahia de
tamanho e do seu próprio tamanho a gente
consegue preencher com duas baías de
tamanho 2 já falhou então 14 não a tribo
e se a gente continuar pensando sobre
isso a gente vai conseguir fazer uma
sequência de números que vai iniciar
assim 235 7 11 13
pensei sobre isso bom depois a gente
conhece os números primos a gente
consegue fazer perguntas sobre números
temos uma das perguntas que a gente pode
fazer é quantos prêmios será que existem
perguntas sobre isso e eu quis conseguiu
dar uma resposta convincente o
suficiente pra que a gente entender se
que existem infinitos números primos não
sou louco pensar nisso né
mas além da pergunta a gente pode fazer
tantas outras por exemplo será que a
gente consegue criar uma fórmula
matemática uma equação que a gente
consiga descrever os números primos para
descobrir por exemplo o próximo
ou será que a gente pegar um número
qualquer que seja a gente consegue
descrever ele com a soma de exatamente
três números primos
bom essas são perguntas que matemáticos
fazem por aí
o mais interessante dizer é que essas
perguntas
elas ainda não têm respostas então a
gente conhece os números primos a gente
consegue listar os números primos a
gente faz perguntas que são simples
sobre os números primos mas não
significa que essas respostas são
triviais e aí que o matemático vai
entrar como esses números são infinitos
faz parte do interesse da matemática
descobrir qualquer com maior que a gente
consegue descobrir então então existem
computadores que rodam um dia e noite
algoritmos para descobrir um próximo
número primo em agosto de 2019
esse número aqui o dois elevadores 32
milhões quinhentos e oitenta e nove mil
novecentos e trinta e três - um erro
maior número primo conhecido até hoje
bom a gente tem perguntas a gente
consegue respondê las
e aí então que a gente consegue usar as
suas respostas para avançar a ciência ea
tecnologia então toda a matemática vai
ser pura até ela ser aplicada
bom mas olha que logo há dois mil anos
atrás a gente começou a pensar sobre os
números primos e hoje eles são
responsáveis por manter seguro porque as
senhas dos bancos
as mensagens que vocês enviam em
aplicativos
elas são todas criptografadas o que
significa imagina que você também está
em família numa mensagem essa mensagem
não será co disse ficada ea partir do
momento que ela vai ser codificado ela
tenha uma senha porque você consegue
tirar essa mensagem ou colocar ela
inteirinha rosa de novo
você concorda comigo que essa senha que
está criptografado ela não pode ficar
solta por aí porque senão a gente
estaria inseguro certo bom e aí que
entram os números primos deles são tipos
guardiões dessas chaves
então o que vai acontecer é que a gente
vai pegar um grande número primo pra
poder codificar essa nossa senha
esse é um tipo de criptografia e você
imagina que assim se conhecesse os três
números frios estivesse parado ali no
treze igual toquei no slide
é fácil encontrar as nossas senhas
então é por isso que a gente tem
computadores rodando números encontram
coisas como esses que eu acabei de
mostrar a vocês que têm mais de 24
milhões de casas decimais bom você já
deve ter escutado que a matemática tá
por aí né
acabei de falar por aí não tá mas
entenda eu não estou dizendo que você
precisa saber essa matemática para
conseguir viver no mundo que a gente
vive hoje eu estou dizendo que é pra
gente viver nesse mundo que a gente está
a gente precisou da matemática
então você pode me perguntar mais justo
se eu não quero contribuir para o
desenvolvimento da matemática então
porque eu preciso aprender matemática
responder essa pergunta eu vou assumir
que todo mundo aqui gostaria de viver em
um universo em que tenham pessoas que
sejam capazes de resolver problemas
analisar informações sejam pessoas que
sejam capazes de tomar decisões
responder respostas responde respostas
inclusive de diversas formas diferentes
e isso tudo o que estou dizendo
significa uma classe de competências
pessoais e vocês prepararam alguma
similaridade com a maneira que eu
apresentei matemática aqui como as
competências pessoais
eu não estou dizendo que matemática são
competências o que competência são
matemática mas estou dizendo que a
matemática é uma excelente maneira a
gente atinge e melhorar as nossas
competências pessoais e se a gente quer
viver num mundo em que a gente consiga
investir e avançar em tecnologia e
educação a gente precisa de pessoas que
consigam ter essas ferramentas e os alas
bom eu já corri formado em licenciatura
em matemática mas na internet as pessoas
me conhecem como a nota maníaca por
conta de um trabalho de divulgação
científica que eu faço
a júlia quando ela entra na universidade
eu acho que ela ter uma sala alguns
alunos mas ela nunca imaginou que esta
sala teria assim 70 mil pessoas
discutindo uma temática com ela e nesse
espaço de incentivo que todo mundo
aprenda um conceito independentes ea
gente vai aplicar ou não então assim o
incentivo que essas pessoas elas busquem
o conhecimento e não rejeito de maneira
alguma e essa educação que eu acredito
hoje bom
a matemática existe a gente tem um
cérebro capaz de aprender matemática
então quando me perguntam jogo porque
seu cabelo verde ou jo porque é
matemática eu respondo com a mesma
pergunta por que não matemática
obrigada
[Aplausos]